YOU PLOP DOWN IN BED AFTER A NIGHT OF DRINKING
ONLY TO FEEL THE ROOM SPINNING WILDLY AROUND
YOU...YOU HAVE THE DREADED SPINS.
HERE'S WHY THEY HAPPEN.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
HEY THIS IS ANNIE FOR DNEWS.
SO LET'S SAY YOU HAD ONE TOO MANY TONIGHT.
YOU STUMBLE ONTO YOUR BED OR THE NEAREST COUCH
TO CRASH, BUT ONCE YOU CLOSE YOUR EYES YOU
GET THE SENSATION OF SPINNING OUT OF CONTROL
ON THE WORLD'S LEAST ENJOYABLE MERRY GO ROUND...OFTEN
ALONG WITH NAUSEA AND DOUBLE VISION THAT MAKES
IT IMPOSSIBLE TO GET THE SLEEP YOU NEED.
YOUR OPTIONS ARE TO WAIT IT OUT, OR TO WRAP
YOURSELF IN A COLD PORCELAIN EMBRACE TO RID
YOURSELF OF THE TOXINS...AND HOPEFULLY GET
TO SLEEP..
GOOD TIMES.
BUT WHAT CAUSES IT?
OTHER THAN THE OBVIOUS ANSWER OF THE FOUR
SHOTS OF FIREBALL YOU TOOK TONIGHT, THE SPINS
HAVE TO DO WITH YOUR INNER EAR.
IN THERE, YOU HAVE SEMI CIRCULAR CANALS THAT
ARE FILLED WITH A FLUID, CALLED endo-lymph
and a gelationous structure called the cupula.
IN THE CUPULA ARE CELLS COVERED IN TINY HAIRS.
THIS IS CALLED THE vestibular system, AND
IT HELPS TO REGULATE YOUR BALANCE.
WHEN YOU DRINK A LOT, THE ALCOHOL THINS YOUR
BLOOD - AND WHEN THE INNER EAR RECEIVES THIS
THINNED BLOOD, IT THROWS OFF THE DENSITY BETWEEN
THE FLUID AND THE CUPULA - CAUSING THOSE TINY
HAIRS TO BEND ARTIFICIALLY.
THIS IS WHAT SENDS A FALSE SIGNAL TO YOUR
BRAIN THAT YOU'RE ROTATING WHEN YOU'RE REALLY
NOT.
AND GUESS WHAT PARTY ANIMALS - MIXING BOOZE
WITH WEED IS OFTEN REPORTED AS MAKING THE
SPINS WORSE, AT LEAST ANECDOTALLY - LIKE ON
THIS YAHOO!
ANSWERS THREAD.
BUT IT IS PROVEN THAT ALCOHOL AND POT CAN
AMPLIFY EACH OTHER'S EFFECTS.
INTERESTINGLY, A 2001 STUDY SHOWED THAT PEOPLE
WHO SMOKED MARIJUANA AND THEN DRANK ALCOHOL
ENDED UP WITH HIGHER THC LEVELS IN THEIR BLOOD
THAN THOSE WHO HAD JUST SMOKED THE POT.
ONE EXPLANATION IS THAT ALCOHOL CAUSES CHANGES
IN YOUR BLOOD VESSELS AND INCREASES ABSORPTION
OF THC.
SO NO - CONTRARY TO WHAT THAT ONE GUY FROM
COLLEGE TOLD YOU ONCE - SMOKING WEED IF YOU'RE
DRUNK WILL NOT "SOBER YOU UP".
IN FACT, THE TWO CAN ADD UP TO MORE THAN THE
SUM OF THEIR PARTS...IN TERMS OF YOUR BUZZ,
AND THE CONSEQUENCES YOU MAY FACE LATER.
BUT LET'S SAY IT'S TOO LATE.
THE ROOM IS ALREADY SPINNING AND THERE YOU
ARE LYING IN BED TOO DRUNK TO SLEEP.
NOW THERE'S NO DIRECT SCIENTIFIC SUPPORT FOR
THIS, BUT LOTS OF PEOPLE SAY DROPPING ONE
FOOT ON THE GROUND OR ON A WALL TO COMPENSATE
FOR THE DISORIENTATION YOUR INNER EAR IS HANDLING,
CAN HELP RESTORE BALANCE AND REDUCE THE SPINS.
BREATHING DEEPLY, NOT LOOKING AT MOVING OBJECTS,
AND THROWING UP - AS UNPLEASANT AS THAT IS
- MIGHT HELP YOU GET TO SLEEP FASTER.
BUT I'M NO SCIENTIST, JUST A PERSON WHO HAS
HAD THE SPINS BEFORE AND READS A LOT OF YAHOO!
ANSWERS THREADS.
AND OF COURSE WE'RE OBLIGATED TO SAY...CONSIDER
NOT TAKING THAT 2 AM FIREBALL SHOT.
HAVE YOU EVER HAD THIS BEFORE AFTER DRINKING
TOO MUCH?
ALSO BE SURE TO CHECK OUT OUR PAST EPISODES
ON THE SCIENCE OF HANGOVERS...AND AS ALWAYS,
LET US KNOW YOUR QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS ON
TWITTER AT D NEWS OR ON FACEBOOK AT DISCOVERY
NEWS.
YOU CAN ALSO FIND ME ON TWITTER AT ANNIE GAUS,
AS WELL AS AT MY OTHER SHOW, WHAT'S THE BIG
DEAL.
THANKS FOR WATCHING, SEE YOU NEXT TIME.